في هذه الزاويه من هذا السوق الشعبي
الشرقي لندن عثرنا على هذا المحل الصغير
لبيع الشاي لكن يبدو ان خبره صاحبه في هذا
المجال تمتد لسنوات شهد خلالها مزيدا من
اقبال البريطانيين على انواع الشاي
المتعدده
[موسيقى]
كان من الصعب اقناع الناس بشراء الشاي
القطفه الثانيه مثلا في انجلترا لكن
الانجليز بداوا يشترونه مني لان مذاقه لا
يصبح مرا على الاطلاق فهو ذو جوده عاليه
[موسيقى]
تشير الدراسات الى ان اول شحنه من الشاي
وصلت الى بريطانيا في القرن السابع عشر
عبر المحيطات حيث بدات ثقافه الشيك
كرفاهيه للاثرياء لكنه اصبح اليوم جزءا
اساسيا من حياه البريطانيين حيث يحتسون
اكثر من 100 مليون كوب يوميا وتستورد
البلاد منه كميات كبيره كما ان
البريطانيين يفضلون الشاي الاسود لكن
العامل الاساسي الذي ساهم في ارتفاع
شعبيته هو سمعته كمشروب
[موسيقى]
طبيعي يحمل شير الاسود مزايا من الالف
للياء تبدا بكون مضادا للتاكسد والالتهاب
وثبت انه يساعد في تخفيف التوتر والقلق
وتقليل خطر امراض اوعيه القلب بنسبه 20%
فشرب نحو خمسه اكواب من الشاي يوميا يخفف
الاكتئاب وجفاف الجسم كما انه مرطب كالماء
[موسيقى]
عصيت الشاي الانجليزي حول العالم ما شجع
كثيرين على مواصله الالتزام بالطقوصه
لاسيما تلك التي اشتهرت بين الطبقه
الارستقراطيه من خلال ما اصبح يعرف اليوم
بشاي ما بعد الظهيره وما يصاحبه من
هناك اشكال كثيره لتكيت الشاي منها رفع
الفنجان لاحتسائه من دون رفع الصحن
المرافق له وعند اضافه الحليب او السكر
تحرك الملعقه الى الامام والخلف دون لمس
جوانب الفنجان وعند الارتشاف يعاد الفنجان
الى صحنه وليس الى اي مكان اخر
يبقى كوب الشاي بالنسبه لكثيرين المشروب
الذي يريح اعصابهم لكن الاهم انه في كل
مره نحتسي فيها كوب شاي فاننا بطريقه او
باخرى ندعم ملايين الاسر في الدول الناميه
والفقيره التي تعتمد في عيشها على زراعه
الشاي وهذا واحد من اهداف الامم المتحده
لاحياء يوم الشاي العالمي من حرب اللغه
الجزيره لندن